okay so BuzzFeed react to my videos they
should be good I think PewDiePie
probably does prank videos like with
dick slaps I don't know
a guy like playing pranks with five
weight that lady say did that lady think
I made pranks with pies pranks with pies
you're gonna make it in the YouTube game
that YouTube pranking you got a kidnap
molest her ass assault pies won't get
you anywhere call me two thousand five
hundred videos god damn I make too many
videos I put up with way too much [ __ ]
to make that many videos man make it our
goal at yes that's right that's right
that's not right you call that right
Robin
no so it's like videos of him while he
plays a video game while he plays
different video games but then he throws
like duck videos in between look at that
guy's face same face my father had when
I first showed him one of my videos
Queen I like the beard I like the beard
and I like you
you're the best I'm a his eyes are
beautiful a BuzzFeed
call me at you I yeah it's like very a
GD look at that girl's face yeah yeah
it's like uh like what she's looking at
that it's the phase of her ovaries
exploding some people can't handle the
PewDiePie nests but I still kind of like
want to hit play like keep watching just
cuz I'm serious what's happening trying
really hard to be nice and I can
appreciate that I'm probably gonna have
like a seizure in a second like there oh
well nevermind that and I'm sorry what
do you want from me it's offensive to
people with seizures by the way I think
I'm not gonna understand my own children
when they're born one day you're you're
the same age as I am probably how tight
should this be
it's on five Oh feel like this is
relatable because a lot of people do
curse when they're playing video games
or when they're just getting frustrated
this should not be used on animals
I'm PewDiePie though probably okay what
the [ __ ] mate what a what are you trying
to tell me huh what the [ __ ] oh do
you're slacking to the hair screaming up
at Fabul yeah they have to fit it's
really funny see they get it but like an
11 year old who'd had a lot of mountain
dew is in the body of like a Swedish
supermodel I don't see what you're
saying
I'll have you know that behind this I am
actually a very mature man and that's
not how I drink Mountain Dew by the way
this is how I drink Mountain Dew no
Jesus Christ don't you like check out
another video we made I was so good
rains a lot like that's like you I think
your your blouse isn't cute
take that sometimes he's funny but like
most time he's creepy kind of miss it
[ __ ] sue what do you want from me
sass lifts up that's right man he kind
of creeps me out like I was that [ __ ] to
set me as a man I think you're me
I wonder what he would be like in the
club
it's like a cartoon it's like
hyperactive it's funny it's sad barb
taneous I wouldn't probably have him
over for a party cuz I just feel like
you would be crazy yeah well maybe I
don't want to be over at your party
damn all that screaming ain't nothing
worth screaming like that for I'm not
sure getting murdered alright so that
was Americans reacting to PewDiePie for
the first time my mom sent me this video
actually so thanks mom
if you enjoyed this video leave a thumbs
up check out BuzzFeed watch some
reaction videos and I'll see you breasts
on the other side as always stay awesome
rest my eyes are burning
oh it's getting my nose yes I bought ten
times your size
yeah Oh Oh